and joining us right now from western
new york getting ready for
a big week eight contest against the new
england patriots
in his uh third year of being
a quarterback in the national football
league he is in first place with the
buffalo bills but most importantly he's
a man with a cereal
he is josh allen how are you josh i'm
doing great rich thank you so much for
having me on are you
uh are you are you kidding of course
we're gonna have you on you're a red hot
quarterback on top of a first place team
but most importantly or you've got a
cereal that's going on right now let's
get
right into the most important part about
this you've got a cereal josh what's
this about yeah
yeah it's super awesome and it's called
josh's jacks
kind of like a playoff applejack if you
will it's red and blue
built but here in western new york and
it's all thanks to plbsme
um for allowing me to do this and i
think the most important part
or my favorite part at least
unfortunately the pro she proceeds go to
a shy children's hospital
which is uh you know one of the top
notch facilities down here in western
new york and
they do a lot of great things and great
research and obviously great help with
the kids here so
um some that near and dear to my heart
and something that i'm super
you know excited about to where i'm able
to help
and give back well uh you know josh if
you're like me and i'm assuming you are
because
i'm the quarterback of this show and uh
nfl network and
also i've got a big arm um you i might
not look like it but i do i've got a lot
of game
uh then i i would definitely be part of
deciding what my cereal tastes like and
looks like did you have any say
in in in this process
i mean i basically had total creative
control which is
okay uh some something was super fun it
was a
little uh a little scary at times i
didn't really know which direction i
wanted to go into but
josh jackson spell with the q and that's
something i put in there to make sure
like it was a quarterback cereal and
quarterback should be eating it you know
so
that answers me and that answers my love
loves the red and blue so
it was a it was a really fun process
okay very good um
and so if the bill's mafia likes it uh
it'll taste
uh it won't get soggy and beer that you
drink after
just jumping on a table in a parking lot
is that what you're saying yeah you got
to make sure the table's lit on fire too
okay and i'm fascinated by this sort of
stuff because if i ever had a process of
a cereal i would i would definitely go
in the sugary direction too
um and so uh so apple jacks is that was
that your choice of cereal as a as a
youngster
growing up uh i'm again again in the
state of california right you're
you're a california crowd yeah i mean i
i was a big serial
um junkie back when i was a kid whether
it be
apple jacks if it was cocoa pebbles if
it was
uh frosted flakes or and crunch but i
mean apple jacks was probably my staple
growing up
to have something similar it's pretty
cool okay so and then uh when you
when you i guess uh quality controlled
it when you
when you q seed this did you try it in
milk to make sure that it
is does it is something that that stands
the test of time
required for breakfast yeah i've
probably had too many a couple too many
bowls already of it so
i gotta tone back i gotta make weight on
that make weight on thursday
it's not you're saying it's it's still
fine it's fine but
i guess if you're trying to get ready
for the new england patriots moderation
is basically what you're saying correct
everything's good in moderation okay
josh allen the man who put together
josh's jacks
by the way were available at local
wegmans or top grocery stores or online
at plbse.com joining me here
on the rich isaac show let's uh let's
get into a little bit of football
josh i'm sure you again you know it's
not your first rodeo
uh here uh in the nfl and you have been
in buffalo
long enough to know uh it's been a long
time coming uh
for the bills to take this division and
to take the patriots to the woodshed is
this
something that's on your mind this very
week josh
um i mean i wouldn't say that's what's
on my mind
what i would say is on my mind is we're
going against you know arguably the
greatest coach of all time
but still very very good defense we got
to go up there and do our job
and try to get another win you know
we're looking for number six and
it's a team that's coming off a couple
tough losses and
um one thing i do know you know last
couple years playing against
coach belichick and and this team is
they don't think losing well
and they always try to find ways to come
back the next week and put their best
foot forward so uh we got to be ready
for anything that they throw at us and
uh again this has been their division
for let me see the last
15 to 20 years um until somebody goes
out there and takes it and
uses these opportunities and um
actually physically takes it from you
know that's when somebody will believe
it so we got to go out there and put our
best foot forward and
be ready for anything they can throw at
us so um you're not giving me here at
the rich island show any bulletin board
material for bill belichick to hang up
in new england is that what you're
saying john
yeah correct you know no i'm but i'm i
am being serious and
you know i i respect you know the heck
out of coach belichick and
what he's been able to do and i think
that the patriots are
kind of the staple of what you would
want in an organization and
the long-term success that they've had
there for you know like i said for the
last 20 years it's something that every
franchise aspires to be so um again
we're we're just trying to go out there
and try to get to win number six and
um we got to be prepared for everything
but i'm sure you are aware
in western new york where brady would
just come in year in and year out
and take care of business that this this
is the the time
for the bills to start serving notice on
on their own right i i
would you allow that like this is this
is it this now you feel like you might
be the best team in this division and
it's yours for the taking will you allow
that as a
uh a statement josh um
you know we we feel confident in who we
are as a team and
um you know we haven't played our best
on offense last few weeks so
again we're looking forward to going out
there and
trying to put together some things on
offense and score some touchdowns but
um ultimately it just comes down to down
to doing our job and
um you know like you said western new
york they don't like the patriots very
much and the patriots
don't like us very much so uh it's gonna
be a four quarter dog fight and we're
gonna be ready for
it josh allen here on the rich eisen
show and you just did mention
um the fact that the offense has not
been firing on all cylinders or
something to that effect
over the last couple of weeks in the
first four weeks
um your statistics and your level of
play and your
level of production was through the roof
mvp conversation around in the last few
weeks
it seems tougher what has happened over
the last couple weeks josh
that you could point to here yeah i mean
i think well
obviously look at this titan's game a
couple just
turn over sports by myself that really
cost us
uh the cheats game you know we didn't
get things rolling too early
you know we we punted too often and
didn't end drives and touchdowns and
then last week we moved the ball at will
we didn't punt it once
but we didn't get in uh when we were in
the red zone that's typically a spot
that we're fairly good at but
um i think it really just comes down to
execution making sure that
we're doing doing the right things um
every you know buddy
it takes all 11 guys to go out there and
execute their job and
um kind of go through the play and
whatever coach table calls we got to
make them look right so
i starts with me i got to do better job
and command in the offense and making
sure we're in the right place and
checking us out of the bad ones so
you know we're learning from it and
teams are going to play some more soft
zone and
try to make me be patient but you know
it's something that i'm learning to do
and
i think that was a good example of what
happened last week just taking what they
gave me and
uh moving the ball will but when we have
opportunities we had to go strike
and in terms of that josh allen i mean
can you uh
uh verbalize a little bit more put a
little bit more meat on the bones there
about being patient
that there are defenders and defensive
coordinators out there that might know
you're potentially impatient because you
want to make a big play because you have
the ability to make a big play whether
it's running it or throwing it
and try and maybe uh trap you into doing
something and you
having to battle your impatience can you
walk me through
that development yeah what is that i've
always been a guy
as long as i can remember where i you
know i want the big play i want to throw
touchdowns i want to
you know put numbers on the board and um
you know when teams aren't allowing us
to do that when they're playing two high
safeties and
trying to take away our best receiver
that when when coach stable caused a
shot play if it's not there i got to
find my outlet and find it in a timely
fashion allow them to
to catch the ball um with the max amount
of yards that they can get possible
without defenders by them so
um you know still learning through that
still
seeing different looks in the afl you
know
going into season three i feel like i've
seen quite a bit but
um i think most time the last couple
years teams would try to
play us man and beat us that way and
press coverage and
try to get pressure on me but i think
things kind of switched up this past
uh past few weeks where it's the
opposite it's let's not pressure him
let's
drop seven or eight into coverage and
force him to find
uh some windows and zones uh within our
defense and
and force him to take all the underneath
stuff so it's part of my progression as
a quarterback and i understand that and
i've got a lot of good help in the
quarterback room and my quarterback
coach
dorsey and coach david they've been
doing a really good job so
um something we got to stay on top of
and just be ready for it each and every
week
well you know i've been at this nfl
network thing for quite some time josh
allen since to use a warren snap phrase
you were
knee-high to a jack rabbit back in
central california
um and i've been doing a lot of combines
um
the current uh general manager of the
raiders was with me
uh at the time as a broadcaster mike
mayok when you were at the combine
and you uh took a snap in one of the
drills and you just
you know lightly glided back to right
around the 10-yard line and let one fly
and it landed on the other 25. and i
looked at mike mayok and he looked at me
and kind of raised his eyebrows like yep
that's the arm strength right there what
is the furthest you've ever thrown a
football
josh furthest was in wyoming so i did
get a little assistance from the
elevation yes
uh but it was right around 83 yards
right around 83. yeah are we rounding up
or re-rounding down to the 83
josh we were probably rounding up just a
little bit but
uh yeah 83 was uh that was the number
so i don't know i'm looking up to see if
you're playing in denver at all so you
can play
you can get a little bit of uh some
altitude can you do that in an nfl game
you think
i mean there was one game i think was my
rookie year against the dolphins
um i i threw a ball staying near as hard
as i can and i
my receiver was 60 70 yards downfield
and i
overthrew them just by a little bit
i did and that was just one of those
like i didn't i didn't feel like i threw
it as hard as i could
but my hip fired so hot and it just came
out of my hand
extremely well and it was spinning and
it was
a little warm in miami so it might have
flown a little farther but
it was just one of those that just kind
of even
blew me off guard so uh something i've
toned down a little bit though and i
feel like i've got a little more control
on my ball right now oh understood no
accuracy is is something that you
definitely have improved on as we have
seen so
let's just walk me through this at some
point during a game in your career
let's just say it could even happen this
this weekend against new england
where you have to throw a hail mary to
win it uh at what yardage do you say to
your coach i still got this
give it to me your own what you're on
what we're like i know i can get the
ball in the air
um and get it probably a good four or
five yards deep in the end zone probably
around the
35. you're on 35.
yeah okay because you know you're
probably gonna have to avoid a rush a
little bit even if they're coming at you
with three-man
you're gonna have to roll out a little
bit so right around your own
30-something yard line you can you can
get it in there you think so yeah i
think so
unbelievable what's your relationship
with jim kelly one of my favorite human
beings on on planet earth
josh yeah he's he's been awesome you
know
from the first day got here just you
know he texted me he came to otas and
this is right after he was having some
surgeries and
the thing that things that he's been
able to battle through throughout his
life and still have the same positive
attitude and mentality kind of
showing me what buffalo's like what to
expect
how to really embrace and appreciate the
people and the fans here
um he's been nothing nothing but class
nothing but great to me and my
um you know my family and um treats me
like one of his own so
uh it's been great he texted me almost
after every single game
i i do such a bad job in texting back
sometimes i forget to message him back
and i feel so bad and i have to
text him two or three days later he's
like come on bud i'm like i know jim i
got to get back to you but he's like an
uncle to me and um
you know i appreciate everything that
he's told me so far and
that he's willing to to reach out and um
share his stories and share his football
knowledge with me and
and i know not many places to have
somebody like that so
um you know he's one of the good ones
for sure sure is and he roots for you
and he believes in you and it must be
great for you to know that and
uh josh i appreciate you calling in uh
on the show
congrats on the serial um i'm gonna have
my own children quality control it as
well and i'll get back to you and see
that they're 12
9 and 7. um you know we don't let them
have too many sugary cereals so they'll
be
fired up about josh's jacks um so i'll
let you know
i'll let you know perfect yeah please do
thank you so much you know as if the
pressure's not on enough just understand
too
uh josh you're not just playing for
yourself in buffalo this weekend
um i'm you're a member of the aroma of
the comeback which is my fantasy team
that's won three in a row
um and i've got singletary too so just
know if you want to check out of a play
and drop it down a singletary
or you know uh just understand uh if
that happens
you're making uh more than just yourself
and your fan base happy
i'll see what i can do for you how about
that you know josh i'll take that as a
yes
i'll just take that as a yes thank
thanks for the call really appreciate it
congrats on the start of your career and
let's keep chatting
sounds good thank you so much you got it
that's josh allen at josh allenqv on
twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here